[Music]
law
it's been a while since i've done a
review
on this channel that hasn't been doctor
who
at this point most of the reviews
um go into the break room of geeks which
is my sister channel that
um i don't script hardly anything ever
and as uh
i was gonna say a loser's schedule
doesn't really have one at all and
that's where most reviews have
lived but this one i wanted to talk
about here
and this is a russell t davies
it's a sin which
people have been pestering me for about
a month
to watch the problem is
it premiered in the uk and
only hit uh the states on hbo max
fairly recently actually a couple of
days ago at the time of recording
so what this is is a
five episode miniseries it's not meant
to continue it's a
open and shut story documenting
young gay men and their friends and
family
in england mostly london
from the early eighties to the start of
the nineties
as the aids crisis
takes hold from
the early days of not realizing what the
problem was at
all to the middle times of
so much disinformation so much
misunderstanding to
the start of the 90s of more or less
understanding what it is
and not having that make it really that
much less scary
so i'm going to talk first of all about
the
mini series in and of itself um
as a kind of standard review and then i
want to spend a little time talking
about
what i think this as a piece of work
exemplifies
and certainly within the context of some
of the things that i have talked about
in the past
in terms of representation for queer
people
um and i'm mainly going to talk on the
creative side when i get to there
as opposed to the actors but
stick a pen in that we'll get to it
so the the mini series follows
um primarily colin
roscoe and richie
who by the end of the first episode have
all
met each other and our friends but our
three
um young gay men
um very different in
in their own ways um roscoe and richie
are very flamboyant richie wants to get
into
theater um roscoe is a bit more uh
financial ambition
colin's just a normal guy
like he's gay and he uh you know he's
around
that scene but you know he he works at a
tailors
and he just he just wants to work
and be good at his job and have pride in
what he does
and then you know they they each have
their families who
find out at varying points
that their sons or
brothers or what have you are gay
and respond differently when we actually
meet roscoe for the first time
uh he has been
discovered already and his
family who's nigerian they are
praying about it they're planning to
send him away
he packs a bag comes down to the family
table in a dress tells them all to go
screw themselves and storms out
so that's our introduction to him richie
is
terrified to ever tell his family
because their behavior on a regular
basis
demonstrates very clearly that they will
not
be accepting uh at all
and he just hides that part of himself
from them colin is
i mean he's too shy to really be too
open with anybody it's actually one of
the most adorable things that's in the
first episode
he's having a conversation with someone
who's just met at his job
who's actually played by neil patrick
harris
and this guy is
you know he's he's a little flamboyant
he's uh you know he's a little sort of
fop-ish um but he's
he he can tell and but he
he gives colin an out he says you know
do you
have a girlfriend boyfriend do you wish
you did and sort of continuing down that
that um road and giving colin the chance
to
say oh yeah girlfriend no i wish i had a
girlfriend like he gives him an out
he doesn't pin him against the wall but
he gives them the chance to say it
and when colin says
i wish i had a boyfriend the relief
on his face but of course even this
first episode
which is largely a celebration of these
characters
and of their joy in their lives
and their connections with other people
are filled with portent
because you know what this story
is what it's about
and it's a very safe assumption that
some of these characters that we're
meeting and getting to watch
just love life
are going to get sick and die
so even the early parts there is
a weight there there's a there's a cloud
hanging over everything and then of
course
things start happening
things start to go badly
and there's a time jump of usually a
couple of years
for every episode out of the five so
we're covering
you know leaps in their lives and in
some cases
downturns in their health
and it's a really well done piece
i i wasn't sure
what i was going to get out of this that
i didn't already get out of say
a normal heart which i reviewed a year
or two back
which was a movie and was a story more
of the
new york experience the thing is
i kind of knew and have known for a
little bit
the american side of this story in terms
of
what the
general vibe of the culture was
and what people in positions of power
or health care did or didn't
do about it i didn't really know
the british story of that which is not
to imply that this
is like a grand scale
it actually it it does a really good job
of finding a sense of scale because we
never lose sight of the
core group of characters that we're
dealing with but
through the people who they meet and who
come in and out of their lives and the
places they go and the ways they
interact
you get a sense of the scope of the
problem
while never lose citing the of these
characters and then the last episode the
fifth episode
gets so small
and i mean that in terms of focus
in terms of how personal it gets
how much it comes down to let's
zero in on one
person and the impact to that person and
the people around them
and given that up to that point it had
been a year's
spanning story of multiple characters
that's a
bold thing to do and it it was the right
thing to do
and now i want to start to transition
into talking about
putting this into the context of when i
talk about
creators writing their experience or
people trying to step outside of writing
their experience
because i've gone on record in the past
of expressing
frustration when certain creatively
minded people
be they writers or actors or directors
who don't have
the life experience of queer people
try to tell queer stories
they can come across as very tone deaf
and that's not limited to just
queer issues i mean you can look at the
fallout that's happening right now
with sia's movie music and the
fallout from the autistic community to
see the kind of ways that
someone who thinks
that they know and thinks they can tell
a story that
they do not have direct experience with
what can result from that
by contrast it's a sin
is what happens
when a gay man writes his life
experience because
russell t davies was
an active gay man in that
social climate in
england in the early 80s
he lived a lot of this and none of these
uh characters are direct analogs to
really like real life people
though there are a few nods to such so
like
richie who is the one who wants to act
he he gets to be in a doctor who story
and they make one up
uh like it's not an actual they don't
make it a one-to-one make it clear
you know what he's actually in but
that's inspired by the actor who played
mike smith in remembrance of the daleks
who was gay davies is really writing his
experience and
he is able to bring the
knowledge and the understanding that
only someone who
understands these experiences can
bring and he does it without this being
a one-to-one
autobiography and i looked into
the writing and the creation of this he
talked about how for
years he did research for this his own
life experience he still
did research this was his life
and he still knew he didn't know
everything
and he had to come at this carefully
which is always what i dread
when people outside the community try
and tell our stories
i dread that they think they won't have
to do this
because even someone who lived this
experience
knew he had to do research he
had to get this right
and this story this
powerful touching
heartbreaking story
of gay men living
and dying
and seeing the impact not only on them
but on their families
episode three was the one that cracked
me the hardest
and spoilers um
for this next thing i'm gonna talk about
colin
the sweet normal
not particularly sexually active
young man he contracts the disease
and in him it manifests
almost as dementia
but in a lucid moment
he's crying on his mother's chest
begging her to make it all right
and his mother knew that he was gay
and was just waiting for him to tell her
she knew and she loved him and she was
accepting of him
and he dies and roscoe even notes the
unfairness of this because roscoe was
far more promiscuous
and his family you know he had to
leave them at the start of the thing
but colin's the one who dies without
having to have a character
monologue and shout to the heavens the
cosmic unfairness of that is made
abundantly clear
and i said how at the end it zeroes in
on one character and that is
richie who spends
most of the fifth episode dying
only somebody with personal experience
and this kind of
insight i think could have written what
happens here because
it is an insane balancing act
that we see richie's parents
and he had not come out to them
prior to being sick
because he knew they wouldn't accept him
and his mother in particular to to see
her that have it be so imminently clear
that she
loves her son she loves him deeply
but she doesn't understand him
and she's not prepared to do the work to
understand him
but still loves him
the ability of davies to write a
character
that is borderline abhorrent
at times but you understand
and there are moments where you can even
tell
she's doing the best she can the fact
that this is the best that she can do
is the tragedy in many ways
but she is trying
and it's still so clearly not enough and
she's not let off the hook
she is called out by multiple people she
is
called out by the mother of another
patient at the hospital
who looks at her and says how old is he
30
for 30 years you looked at him and you
didn't realize this about him
who did you see who were you looking at
what is wrong with you and then later on
jill who was whose
good friends with all these people she
says very plainly to his mother you
instilled
shame in him and because of
shame he didn't tell you and because of
shame
he didn't even properly confirm that he
had this disease for a long time and
even after he had it
he still went and saw men because he was
too
ashamed he would do that
he would pass the disease and he
would just feel shame and it would
cycle
and it also doesn't let richie off the
fact for that
you can tell that
this world that davey's inhabited and is
recreating for the screen
he's not looking at it
with rose tinted glasses he is taking a
critical eye he is acknowledging
the problems that existed everything
from old men perving on
young vulnerable gay men to the
knowing passing on of this disease from
people who are
unwilling to get themselves tested or
people who are unwilling to properly
cope with the fact that they are sick
and it gives an unflinching look at
all of this now i do want to say
don't take my point to this and saying
this is what happens when you let queer
people tell
tell their own story as saying just give
free reign to all
queer creators because russell t davies
is a very
talented and skilled writer
so it is that combination
of being a skilled writer and writing to
his own life experience that creates
something as good as this
because if he wasn't a skilled writer
well
then you get glenn or glenda
which was ed woods first movie
so just because you're telling your own
story doesn't mean that you're gonna do
it
any justice
but if a queer story is going to be told
i think it needs to be
with the heavy involvement if not the
primary creative force behind it being
queer people and one of the things i
found out looking into this series
was this was disturbingly hard for
russell t davies to get off the ground
he went to multiple channels
who all turned him down and didn't want
to touch the subject matter and even the
one that eventually aired it which was
channel 4 in the uk
they initially passed on it and it was
only when their head of drama
programming
went to bat for this project and for
davies
now as a reminder russell t davies
created torchwood brought back
doctor who created years and years
created the original version of queer as
folk he is a hit maker
and he has done this kind of subject
matter
these kind of characters in the past to
great success and acclaim
and he still almost didn't get to
make it so when i express
my frustration and sometimes frankly
fury
at people like scarlett johansson who
wanted to play a trans man
and rupert sanders who was gonna direct
that movie and this was years ago i know
but it still frustrates me
when i express my rage at that it's
because
they got financing in a heartbeat
and it only fell apart after people
started calling them out on it
russell t davies who knows this material
who lived it who is a queer creator who
has created many
massive hits for television who has
created
massive queer hits for television had
to fight and go to multiple places
to be able to tell this story
that is screwed up
we are infrequently brought to the table
to tell our own stories
and when we want to even those of us
with clout
when we try to tell our own stories
there are way more hurdles than there
should ever be
for us to be able to do that but he did
he did get to tell it
and if you haven't seen it's a sin
please do if you have hbo max watch it
it is wonderful it is sad
but not completely devastating at least
i didn't find it to be such like
davey's being devastated is torchwood
children of earth
which broke me and left me
in a very dark place and
while there were points when i had a
good cry
during this
it didn't leave me in a place of
darkness
it left me in a place of hope and
defiance
to not let this sort of thing happen
again
i hope you will support queer creators
especially when they are trying to tell
queer stories
thank you very much for watching i don't
have any sponsors
but i have a patreon and if you'll
indulge me next month
is my birthday
if you're feeling generous and you want
to do something for it what i would
actually ask
is that you support the patreon
it's how i pay my bills it's my living
but if you are already supporting the
patreon
or if you truly would rather do
something else
you'll find links to not only my amazon
wishlist but also
my etsy wish list which i recently added
and then further down the description
is my p.o box i hope you don't mind
indulging me i like
to be spoiled i'm an only child it comes
with the territory
but it's a sin have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments and let's talk about it
like share subscribe they all help me
out
but you don't have to do any of it if
you don't want to
because at the end of the day you are
the council
i am only running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh